bonsoir nous sommes le 24 avril nouvelle
édition du 7 8 l'actu 18h si vous nous
rejoignez en direct et au cours du
prochain quart d'heure il sera notamment
question de la déclaration d'impôts 2013
également de l'ouverture ce week-end des
praires à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
manifestation solidaire et puis les
images de la future préfecture des
Yvelines les travaux qui viennent tout
juste de débuter mais tout d'abord
retour sur ce déplacement de la
secrétaire d'État l'enseignement
supérieur à la recherche Geneviève
fioration
elle était à l'école polytechnique pour
poser la première pierre de futur
laboratoire de sciences à l'occasion
aussi pour elle de saluer la grande
université Paris Saclay qui va prendre
forme à 17 automne et pour TV Phil elle
est revenue sur la situation de
l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines la crise
budgétaire est passée il y a des efforts
à faire elle s'explique au micro de
Catherine zulato et de Michael Jarry
ce que j'ai voulu d'abord rassurer les
étudiants les familles donc pour cela
nous avons d'abord versé 800.000 euros
pour assurer le paiement des salaires
puis 2 millions 600 millions d'euros ce
qui ne peut même pas rien en avance
remboursable pour là encore assurer la
pérennité de l'université mais nous
avons aussi demandé des efforts 15000
étudiants plus de 46 d'implantation de
cet université ça n'était vraiment pas
possible d'autant que certains de ces
sites sont remplis seulement pour le car
donc le quart des bâtiments donc il y
avait une rationalisation opérée il y
avait des PPP renégocier il y avait un
sérieux budgétaire à rétablir et puis il
y avait un accompagnement et une
formation à la fois de l'équipe de
gouvernance et puis de l'équipe de
direction c'est ce que nous avons fait
le délai ce sera deux ou trois ans sera
le temps nécessaire au redressement
et les premières économies annoncées ne
passent pas du côté des étudiants
notamment celles concernant les
bibliothèques avec un budget de
fonctionnement de presque 60000 euros
contre les 175000 demandés par les
organisations étudiantes qui siègent au
conseil d'administration plusieurs sons
conséquences sont à attendre à commencer
par la fermeture tous les samedis de
l'ensemble des bibliothèques
universitaires le report également des
achats de livres à 2015 et la fermeture
définitive de la bibliothèque médicale
de Boulogne interasso UVSQ première
organisation représentative des
étudiants demandent à rencontrer la
direction à revenir sur cette mesure
alors que débute bientôt les examens
l'organisation qui demande également à
la région et aux élus de la Communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin et
d'intervenir
comme à chaque printemps les
déclarations d'impôts sont arrivés dans
les boîtes aux lettres plusieurs
changements sur le plan pratique mais
aussi fiscal si le barème a été dégelé
permettant aux ménage ayant des revenus
stables de payer moins il faudra aussi
prendre en compte la baisse du plafond
du quotient familial ou encore la baisse
du plafond des niches fiscales Catherine
zulato fait le point ce soir sur la
situation fiscale dans le département
des Yvelines
les Yvelines ne comptent 738 1179 foyers
fiscaux et parmi eux 68% sont imposables
ces 68% de foyers imposables ont permis
en 2013 au service des impôts de
recouvrer un peu plus de 2 milliards et
demi d'euros certains contribuables
payent l'ISF l'impôt de solidarité sur
la fortune le service des impôts des
Yvelines a enregistré 15197 déclarations
soumises à l'ISF cela concerne les
contribuables dont le patrimoine net
taxable et supérieur à 1,3 millions
d'euros les contribuables ont jusqu'au
mardi 20 mai pour déposer leurs feuilles
papier et jusqu'au 10 juin s'il déclare
en ligne en 2013 44% des foyers
yvelinois avaient choisi ce mode de
déclaration si vous souhaitez des
informations des renseignements le
département dispose de 9 centres des
finances publiques dont un à 50 ans
niblyn qui sera ouvert sans discontinuer
de 8h30 à 16 heures du 5 au 20 mai
les invités de ce 24 avril à présent à
l'embry et bonsoir vous êtes commissaire
général de la prairie à la Montigny
membre du LionZ club également l'une des
plus importantes ONG au niveau mondial
et puis Frédéric Pellegrin bonsoir à
vous vous êtes le vice-président
l'actuel vice-président du Lion's Club
de Montigny samedi et dimanche 11e
édition de cette fête des fleurs et des
jardins ce sera comme d'habitude à la
Ferme du Manet comme d'habitude
également les bénéfices iront à la lutte
contre la cécité on va revenir tout
d'abord sur l'origine de cette
manifestation comment les prairiales se
sont mises en place il y a maintenant 11
ans 10 ans c'est l'angiène édition et ça
a commencé en 2003 et il n'y a eu aucune
interruption et ça prouve l'intérêt du
public pour cette manifestation qui
attend cette période de l'année pour
pour enrichir son jardin et cette
manifestation est partie d'une d'une
discussion qui est du Lion's club et du
et de la ville de Montigny en disant il
se passe quelque chose de bien à
Rambouillet si vous montiez la même
chose à Montigny et comme c'était le
Lion's Club de Rambouillet qui avait
lancé ça bien on a lancé la même
opération à Montigny malheureusement
pour Rambouillet la manifestation s'est
arrêtée mais pour nous à Montigny elle
se porte très bien édition dès le début
il était forcément question de
solidarité et d'aide également envers
ces personnes qui sont atteintes de
cécité le l'un des buts du du Lion's
Club et d'aider les personnes
non voyantes ou atteintes de cécités
donc il y a eu un paquet de campagne
international dans ce domaine là et
notre club a choisi pour cette
manifestation la lutte contre la cécité
sachant que pour d'autres manifestations
comme Armanet on a on choisi la lutte
contre comment la maladie d'Alzheimer ou
des choses comme ça on peut choisir
d'autres thèmes mais on a préféré pour
cette manifestation choisir la cécité et
on est en partenariat avec l'école de
chien guide d'aveugle de Paris et de la
région parisienne cette école de chiens
guide a été comme toutes les écoles de
chien guide en France
financés au départ par les liens clubs
qui ensuite ont ces écoles ont pris leur
indépendance les fonds récoltés lors de
chacune des manifestations permettent
justement d'acheter ensuite ces chiens
on achète pas un chien on participe à
son financement parce que ça coûte à
hauteur de 15000 euros c'est à peu près
ça c'est à dire que si on prend un chien
son achat sa vaccination
son éducation les frais vétérinaires et
sa retraite parce que il y a un chien
vers 9 ans par en retraite et bien on
considère que ça coûte à peu près 15000
ans quels sont les objectifs de cette
année l'an dernier plus de 10000 euros
récoltés pour le vice-président quel est
l'objectif fixé cette année on va
essayer de faire autant aussi mieux
après on a un paramètre qui est
impondérable sur lequel on a aucune
influence c'est la météo on expose donc
environ 60
stands tournés sur la vente de fleurs et
de plantes donc la majorité est en plein
air dans une prairie sur la ferme du
manex exactement donc là l'influence de
la météo sera fondamentale pour
encourager les gens à venir nous
rencontrer à venir se promener déjà
comment ça va se dérouler il y a des il
y a cette manifestation principale il
faut payer un droit d'entrée et puis
ensuite on peut ensuite papillonner
d'instant à un autre il y a des
animations également des conférences qui
sont prévues comme le prix d'entrée
c'est 2,50 € et ce Billet est uniquement
payé par les adultes c'est à dire que
les enfants ne payent pas une famille
qui vient ne paye que 5 euros ce qui
n'est pas hors de prix ça permet à tout
le monde de venir mais de faire un geste
de solidarité et avec ce billet on peut
entrer autant de fois qu'on veut c'est à
dire qu'on peut vider la prière de
toutes les plantes avec un seul billet
alors est-ce qu'il y aura aussi d'autres
animations
il y aura une animation en partenariat
avec l'UCPA la Ferme du Manet où on aura
samedi après-midi de 14h à 17h et
dimanche de au même heure des promenades
en poney et on aura une ou deux
manifestations on n'a pas encore
finalisé encore le programme d'une part
sur les pierres et d'autre part sur le
la partie écologique d'un jardin donc on
organise des deux conférences le samedi
de conférence le dimanche et on aura mis
le programme à l'entrée en gros il y en
aura une vers
15h et une vers 17h on va des images des
précédentes éditions ça mobilise
énormément de monde comment ça se passe
l'organisation pour le lance club alors
la prairia est un une action qui est
quand même très important pour nous
clubs de Montigny les trois villages
exactement
grosso modo tout le tous les membres du
club sont sollicités donc environ 15
personnes participent à la hauteur de
leur capacité de leur disponibilité
aussi ça a commencé dès aujourd'hui pour
quelques préparatifs sur le site et ça
continuera jusqu'à lundi pour le
démontage le nettoyage le retrait
signalétique et inhérente à ce salon là
tout simplement on parlait tout à
l'heure des objectifs financiers puisque
c'est important c'est une manifestation
solidaire vous l'avez bien compris vous
me disiez avant que nos débuts de cet
entretien donc ne débute le journal que
vous saviez déjà à peu près que vous
alliez récolter au moins 6000 euros ça
c'était sûr oui ça c'est à peu près sûr
puisque les commerçants ou les exposants
ont un droit de participation à droite
participation qui est qui est faible
c'est 10 fois moins cher que
Saint-Jean-de-Beauregard par exemple
c'est vraiment
un grand stand coûte 170 euros à peu
près et donc les commerçants réservent
leur stand et ça nous permet de d'avoir
déjà un petit un petit volant de
financier mais surtout de payer tous les
frais fixes qui sont la sécurité les la
sonorisation des choses comme ça on a
entre deux et 3000 euros de frais fixe
pour pouvoir monter la manifestation le
panotage le de toute la communication
qui est à faire merci à tous les deux
d'être venu sur ce plateau nous parler
de cette manifestation 11e prêt real
Ferme du Manet à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
samedi 26 dimanche 27 avril merci encore
à vous deux si vous êtes un amoureux des
plantes justement ce week-end sera
chargé en marge de ses prairies à la
Montigny-le-Bretonneux les serres
municipales d'Élancourt vont ouvrir
leurs portes ce samedi les jardiniers de
la mairie vont exposer leurs plus belles
créations florales et aussi livré
quelques-uns de leur précieux conseils
visites en avant-première avec ce
reportage
à Elancourt les trois fleurs qui
s'affichent sur les panneaux de la ville
ne doivent rien au hasard dans les
serres municipales André le responsable
de la production s'active avant le rush
du printemps
de rester pratiquement sur les serres et
tout ce qui fait déco sur la ville tout
ce qui est décoration intérieure floral
pour toutes les manifestations
culturelles sportives
rempotage repiquage ou mise en place des
jardinières et des massifs dans la ville
ce sont les jardiniers qui donnent de la
couleur dans les rues c'est un petit peu
le phénomène de mode on a vu que bon il
y avait beaucoup de gens l'année
dernière qui préférait le rose un petit
peu le blanc donc on s'est dit cette
année on va essayer le rose blanc et
puis l'année prochaine on choisira un
autre coloris quoi on prend un petit peu
la température avec les portes ouvertes
en 2013 la commune a consacré 87000
euros à son fleurissement Hervé Bernay
le responsable a vu la ville changer
depuis son arrivée il y avait quasiment
rien ici donc on arrivait tout ça on est
arrivé là maintenant bon bah
même pour la ville quoi je veux dire
c'est ville fleurie c'est quand même
plus agréable enfin je pense enfin
j'espère pour tous les amateurs de
belles plantes les serres s'ouvrent au
public ce samedi 26 avril un moment de
partage qui permet au jardinier de
préparer les prochaines saisons ça a
pourtant d'échanger avec les gens qui
sont sur la commune parce que bon ils
seront pas compte forcément du travail
que ça représente aussi à l'intérieur il
voit sur la ville comment ces
positionner mais derrière tout ça il y a
un travail quand même qui est assez
important sur l'année
plus de 400 curieux c'était bousculé les
années précédentes pour recevoir les
conseils avisés des jardiniers ouverture
des portes à 9 heures
on quitte la nature pour parler
urbanisme à présent la préfecture ce
modernise des travaux sont prévus
pendant une durée de 9 mois ce qui va
changer pour les usagers c'est avec les
explications de ce sujet
c'est parti pour 9 mois de travaux à la
préfecture des Yvelines les services
situés avenue de l'Europe à Versailles
fermente au public là au plus de 300
personnes transit chaque jour ils
viennent notamment pour des documents
liés à la route ou des demandes de
titres pour les étrangers le temps des
travaux à un important dispositif de
substitution et donc mis en place au
programme plusieurs changements pour la
délivrance d'une carte grise d'un permis
de conduire ou d'un renouvellement de
titre de séjour pour les étrangers
inutile de se déplacer toutes les
démarches se feront par voie postale en
téléchargeant les documents sur le site
internet de la préfecture et d'autres
changements sont aussi à prévoir pour
les les militaires et les pompiers qui
veulent des passeports de mission ça se
fera à la mairie de Versailles qui nous
a gracieusement prêté un local
et puis pour d'autres démarches nous
avons donc ouvert réouvert ici l'ancien
hall d'accueil de la préfecture rue Jean
Houdon pour une partie des démarches
d'étrangers notamment les demandeurs
d'asile ou les demandeurs de premier
test de séjour ou les demandeurs de
titres spéciaux commerçants artistes etc
nous ouvrons également un local rue de
Noailles près de la gare des Chantiers
pour une autre d'autres types de
démarches et également pour les
personnes qui demandent leur
naturalisation française ou celle qui
veulent un titre de voyage pour leur
enfant mineur et quand on remise de
titres de séjour elles seront faites à
la mairie de Trappes qui nous a prêté un
local sécurisé de façon à recevoir les
personnes et leur donner leur titre de
séjour
très sonore une ventilation incorrecte
il fallait des conditions plus modernes
d'accueil un des premiers travaux de
l'architecte structuré le hall en
organisant au mieux les services et les
flux de circulation mais pas seulement
second travail c'est la qualité de
l'espace avec l'aspect lumière l'aspect
thermique évidemment faire en sorte que
sous la verrière qui est un espace très
chaud aujourd'hui nous n'ayons pas ces
effets d'apport thermique et que nous
traitons avec des systèmes de
brise-soleil et puis dans les zones au
contraire qui sont trop sombres nous
avons des systèmes depuis lumière que
nous implantons de façon à capter la
lumière et avoir un éclairage naturel
qui vient inonder de lumière les
nouveaux espaces
réouverture prévue fin janvier début
février 2015
merci de nous avoir suivi ce journal et
maintenant terminé rendez-vous demain
vendredi pour une nouvelle édition
excellente soirée sur notre antenne